Ich bin im Aufklärungsbataillon 3 in Mistelbach, in Niederösterreich.
Ich bin Zeitsoldat und sitze auf unserem Husar am Richtschützenplatz.
Als Richtschütze bedient man hauptsächlich die Waffenstation und beobachtet das Umfeld mit der Kamera.
Es ist unser Auftrag ein Lagebild zu schaffen, Informationen bei Tag oder Nacht zu sammeln
und wir führen das bis zu einem gewissen
Punkt motorisiert, also mit Fahrzeugen, durch.
Wenn wir näher zu unserem Aufklärungsziel kommen bewegen wir uns zu Fuß.
Ich bin im Aufklärungsbataillon 3 in Mistelbach und bin dort Gruppenkommandant einer Aufklärungstruppe
und zurzeit einer der wenigen Soldaten die mit der Drohne in Österreich unterwegs sind.
Das besondere an dieser Drohne ist das sie mit einer mobilen Antenne ausgestattet ist,
das heißt wir können die Drohne starten
und können dann mit dem Fahrzeug die Drohne begleiten
um so längere Distanzen zu gewährleisten.
Wir arbeiten auch viel mit anderen Bataillonen
zusammen und auch mit den Luftstreitkräften.